welcome to your mom's house
you look like a piece of a SS Thanks
yeah and that's all I could think about
when I saw that clip of you I could only
think of this really yes have you ever
had the taste of Chinese semen that
haircut by the way
that's I have actually love the haircut
that road rolls haircut you do yes and
what did it make what it taste like soy
sauce yeah salty flavoring I do I love
the salty flavoring and understand will
cook every time you swallow Chinese soy
sauce semen so I think there's billions
and billions of sea monkeys floating and
swimming in your stomach would you like
some today would you like to compare a
contrast white boy semen oh yeah yeah
that would be wonderful
I want like what you didn't hear that
and here we go I want oh whoa oh wow lie
back huh hello white boy come I want a
job yeah pretty cool mmm tastes like
salami
my favorite is always the dumb girl
nervous the poor girl laughs
this is like kind of like the Kumgang
product that we tried to pitch the shark
tank because this girl is comparing all
the different races you know right I
feel like Shark Tank thanks my boy
please next way oh boy please hit the
lab after every session you're an
important point I said
it's so gross
what do you think I just sent you an
email I forgot to send it to you before
it there's some songs I want you to hear
the songs that the squared you sent it
to try sir email my email which would
account me dark huh
okay think about is doing like if that
was my job swallowing calm can anything
worse in life
I would rather bathe in the Japanese
food Aleph every stranger in LA give
them a bath I'd rather sponge bath
strangers than blit legs suck there
they're making oh yeah they're making
soy sauce barf
done I'm not done I think that was like
fungi soup or something wow she know how
to say that shit yeah mayo and noodles
don't mix you know what's crazy is it
she's worse is that there's so many
loads being right no yours tastes like
this is one year's work and it's
yay what's he saying you're ready retard
said I got here with all my kids I got I
came with all my kids you know like my
kids are in your mouth basic that is so
fucking gross God yeah why does he have
to personalize it like that we stopped
listening to them yeah it's always over
freedom America yeah that was definitely
definitely frijoles and barfi is all the
way i was so noisy dude that's the worst
job in the world I would rather dig
ditches and pick up garbage in the
streets for the rest of my life and do
what that woman did in that one clip
seriously seriously dig ditches
I'd rather pick up at garbage all day
every day by the freeway really yep then
do that one scene anything worse I mean
no if you're if you're asking me I would
definitely dig those ditches - for the
rest of my day every day ninety years
old you don't I'm happy about it happy
shit I'll have to blow these eight guys
yeah compare those nuts yeah